pierre de saint pierre desproges vers
des projets moins bien aussi parce que
c'est le couple jeune afrique a bu
minute avait dit que les invitera
ensemble c'était pas vrai mais pierre
desproges manuel de savoir vivre à
l'usagé des rustres des malpolis c'est
encore un coup dur maintenant je fais de
la pub pour cette collection je voulais
faire ça c'est le même que calamity jane
oui bah tant pis il se trouve qu'ils ont
publiées vous avez un bon éditeur rien
de sa collection point virgule cdu poche
manuel à savoir viser les autres replis
nous ça nous fait beaucoup rire si
j'aime folie était pas brouiller avec
moi depuis samedi dernier et non parce
qu'elle a fait un premier essai par
coeur de nyala dit des choses justes
oui bien sûr mais dans tous les livres
de pierre desproges parker bah oui ne
faudrait pas répéter mon édition pierre
ça vous dirait nous en livre un petit
bout oui tu verras que pour ça je viens
vous en parle pas de cul on parle de
cons c'est vraiment un vrai manuel
sourire à lisier il s'agit là dans ce
chapitre qui très intéressante de
reconnaître les cons oui alors
existe-t-il des signes extérieurs de
conneries oui on peut reconnaître un con
rien qu'à sa façon de s'habiller
la caractéristique vestimentaire du
conte consiste en a besoin irrésistible
de s'habiller comme tout le monde
faites le test suivant les enfants aux
yeux je m'étais dit personnes dans une
pièce observez bien ces dix personnes
sur ces 10 personnes il y en a au moins
une qui est habillé comme les neuf
autres c'est un con ces scientifiques
quand 40 personnes s'habille comme un
con c'est l'académie française
huit cent mille personnes s'habille
comme un con c'est l'armée française où
l'armée soviétique peu importe
d'ailleurs il y en a une que j'aimais
beaucoup mais vous les fameux la lyre et
maintenant c'est trop tard
oui c'est elle la lettre trésor public
mon cher 13 heures c'était vraiment le
mien